then he went Donald Trump killed Donald
Trump I love Donald Trump but no more
dropped by the drop boxes are just so
bad no more drop boxes Dickinson holagic
and cephe cephahide
that was about a guy named a rhino named
Mitt Romney Mitt Romney real Beauty had
to give the American people their voice
back by building something called truth
truth essential
against Kate's law and he voted for
Obama
amnesty you know we've endorsed Dr Oz
we've endorsed
JP right J.D Mandel and he's doing great
I've had more investigations and Jesse
James Billy the could some of the
world's greatest cricket players from
as the great religious teacher Swami
Vive come on what's that
I hope they now go and take a look at
the oranges or the oranges of the
uh investigation the beginnings of that
investigation and God bless
United States thank you very much he was
awarded the broad star and the combat
infantryman badge for his service we
have to keep our country gay people but
it's not I mean for some reason it's
just not great anymore if you care about
law and auto look Law and Order in
normal times roughly 40 percent of fresh
vegetables at about 40 percent China
nambia's health system is increasingly
self-sufficient this is not about virtue
cycling and signing and the great
General and President Ulysses S Grant
he's done he's really come back a long
way over the last 10 years hasn't he
very much Tim Apple when they gaze upon
your semites your seminites towering
Sequoias they deliver they swept and
swept in you know that sweeping it was
Swift and it was sweeping like nobody's
ever seen anything happen units of
plasma for plasma donate plasma into
failing New York Times by
an anonymous really an anonymous gutless
coward I may ask Marilyn Lockheed
the leading woman's business the teacher
should ever be allowed to teach
transgender to our children while not
correct up himself
no nobody has to have parental consent
and we will totally oppose the Biden
administrating at this this
Administration uh he made some
statements rough statements on Jewish
you've heard them and you know them well
I'm worried about my espresso machine
I'm not
that can be your hand
for him it's not a joke it's just I'm
worried about my Lane
who did this attack who did this Cyber
attack so you have you know the good
Geeks and they patch it up and they fix
it and they put up better protection
virus protection but here's what my
attorney said he said
um
do you frequently go to Hardee's is that
a common place you go okay that's pretty
funny
that could be your headline the machine
bye
[Music]
Trump was doing this with his personal
toilet but shakes
[Music]
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elephants and bathrooms
10 times 15 times
what on Earth is going on with Trump
toilets
Trump's White House toilet
would be clogged
clogged clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation the big massive dumps
elephants and bathrooms
[Music]
for this personal toy elephants and
bathrooms
[Music]
God bless the United States thank you
very much elements of bathrooms well
welcome everybody it is the I guess sort
of official start to Donald Trump is oh
this thing's off oh God not this again
oh no not with the tech issues again no
I'm kidding I know I'm live you guys
can't trick me uh the first official
2024 rally Donald Trump holding it
momentarily in Waco Texas the site of a
horrible event and I believe it was 1992
or 1993.
um a a very long standoff involving the
Branch Davidians followers of David
koresh I recently actually read Jeff
Gwynn's new book Jeff Gwynn wrote a
fantastic book about the people's Temple
Jim Jones and great book about uh
Charles Manson and most recently this
book just out in January a book called
Waco uh about the entire Siege in Waco
Texas things already out of control as
you see Mike pillow currently being
interviewed his hair is out of control
he's got a big Cross Pin and pointing to
right side broadcasting so we're
monitoring things very very closely here
we are also monitoring uh Trump's
imminent arrival in Waco Texas flanked
by one two three four five six seven
eight nine 10 11 12 30. more than a
dozen flags and as you know whoever has
the most flags obviously would be the
best president it's a very very standard
uh way of evaluating candidates that
we've employed here at the David packman
show for a very long time so it is great
to have everyone here and we are of
course potentially going to see the
arrest and indictment of President
Donald Trump
um any time right I mean any any time
I'm going to tell everybody up front
just so nobody thinks I'm hiding
anything I have a very hard out at 7 30
Eastern I'm going to a friend's birthday
party tonight uh and so it's not a soft
or even a medium firm out it is a hard
out at 7 30. and from what we know uh
and Trump trump actually seems to be
running on time today so it may not end
up being a factor but that's going to be
a thing let's look at our first Super
Chat David as I imagine is the case with
many of your regular listeners thanks to
you I can't hear the name Obama with a
little voice in my head blurting
it's permanently etched in my brain keep
up the good work well I apologize for
that I really really do and we expect uh
we expect many Obama's tonight I think I
will mention big thank you to Pac fans
Jared walking Lisa Lee and the last rap
Dragon I really appreciate your Twitch
Prime subscriptions we do have a coupon
code tonight that code is indict the
code is in Diet it's above my head we
all know what it means thanks to Kevin
gouldy for signing up on my website with
that coupon code all right let's look oh
we are on the ground at the rally I I
don't you know I'm always careful in the
moment because we don't want anybody at
the rally to be tipped off or to be
looking for one of our many different
correspondents but we are on the ground
at the rally
um interviews are being conducted with
Trump supporters and we are going to
have those probably on the Monday show
probably on the Monday show Tim asks
will the audio glitch more or will
Trump's brain glitch more tonight I
always always am hoping for audio
glitches during Trump's speeches but I
think Eric did not like
they lived up I used to check it every
week are they buying are they buying
right deal that included the largest
agricultural
oh
exactly
and our incredible all these people
don't know what the hell they're doing
further scream that his days
[Music]
Trump
exactly so I'm always hoping that antifa
is running audio at Trump's event so a
lot of very very important things going
on tonight let's get to some of the
wacky stuff from the rally okay January
6th prisoner Mickey Olson Larson Larson
who charged the capital dressed as
Captain America is at the rally
indicating that they are ready to fight
boys from our Collective boys our
government of we the people of the
People by the people for the people is
also a terrorist and if they are an
American citizen they are a traitor they
made the decision that we the people no
longer have a right to govern ourselves
I'm a proud digital soldier Okay so
there's a digital Soldier who's ready to
fight reciting some kind of poem Trump
2024 bikinis very widely available at
the rally
um here is Tre uh Ted Nugent calling
Vladimir zielinski gay
[Applause]
I want my money back and the crowd
reacting very positively to the
homophobic comment comments from Ted
Nugent
uh let's see Gustavo says David sir my
girlfriend is jealous because of how
much time I spend watching your videos
Jokes Aside love the show thank you
Gustavo very much appreciate it and
apologies if there are any uh problems
that I'm causing between you and between
you and your girlfriend I don't want to
do that
uh let's see what else do we have
um I'm gonna skip that oh this was
really weird Trump again mentioning that
not all parents love their kids it
really seems like we know what this is
about and I made farmers happy and Rich
again
and they're doing a fantastic job
and you know what
someday it'll become time for them to
leave this beautiful Earth and they'll
be able to leave their farm right
without taxes to their children yep I
got rid of the death tax on farms
so that when you do pass away
on the assumption that you love your
children you can leave it to them and
they won't have to pay tax but but if
you don't love your children so much and
there are some people that don't
and maybe deservedly so it won't matter
is this entire video about Don Jr
because frankly you don't have to leave
them anything thank you very much have
fun
that is so deranged oh my God that he is
out of his mind that is like what a what
a bizarre way of delivering a message
about tax policy I mean just thank you
very much have fun uh wow it is Bonkers
huh really really crazy stuff let's see
what else we have from the
rally looking at a various uh quite
quite a feed here
um Marjorie Taylor green obviously lying
Democrats have weaponized the government
a
fairly able to speak for the crime a
beating Hillary Clinton and winning why
so listen guys I understand she has a
Southern accent I'm not making fun of
her southern accent but does a Southern
accent make you say Clinton like
doesn't make any sense to me is that a
Southern accent am I am I am I making
fun of her accent because she can't say
Clinton
is that inappropriate it is okay let's
move on then in the 2016 presidential
election
we don't consider that a crime do we
no we elected him Law and Order of
course famously is subject to what
people consider to be a crime the law no
longer matters it's we're for Law and
Order
if if I don't personally consider it to
be a crime then it's not a crime wow
pretty pretty powerful Peter says as
coincidental as it sounds for Trump to
do his 24 campaign on an anniversary his
Greatest Hits will be spoken like his
whining of the 2020 Stone stolen
election bingo card is ready thank you
Peter I appreciate you being here thanks
to Beth Graham and Jay Cauley for the
twitch Prime subscriptions great to see
great to see so many people here quite
frankly uh oh let's just see if
anything's going on no no arrival from
Trump yet so we have plenty of time here
uh let's see we looked at that video
already
um
man I just can't I don't even want to
look at Dan Patrick's videos because
they're just they're just so stupid
let's see what for something marginally
less stupid than Dan Patrick let's look
at a pillow video one of the things that
I look at too is that call in Georgia
that call with crooked Brad rasenberger
the secretary of state racenberger
Georgia the last name is raffensberger
Rosenberger when he made that call it
was the best call in history that showed
he had the numbers right in front of him
that the election was fixed that there
was in Georgia he had all the numbers of
the dead people that voted the
non-residents and yet they flipped that
and try and use it against him by sound
biting you know pieces out of there
remember he said find find us some boats
yeah we know well we know exactly what
he said find the horse they were all
there you know they were all there but
um there's so much hope going on right
now in the country I've never been this
hopeful I know downfall parodies asks
via a very powerful super chat should
lefties talk more about the importance
of good personal finance even though we
have an effed up system some people
would be better off if they handled
their money better in my opinion
absolutely you know Noam Chomsky as some
people call him
I say Chomsky but some people say
chompsy he was once confronted with like
Hey listen you know you criticize so
many aspects of our economy but then
like you own the same index funds as
everybody else and Chomsky was basically
like what should I keep cash under my
mattress uh it's a pretty it's a pretty
funny funny clip actually to be
perfectly Frank with you welcome to
Howling Stars thank you for the twitch
Prime subscription I appreciate that
let's keep going because we have so much
stuff here is Matthew Gates wearing uh
well you see what he's wearing
um at the at the rally
and then we looked at this clip already
here is someone who has a plan to fix
the chain supply
some of us are worried about the supply
chain if you're worried about the supply
of chains here's a guy who will fix it
Trump
God
these people
please be I I think I'm going to indulge
just one more time here
I've got a plan to fix the chain supply
it's called re-elect Donald Trump I
could run on that I I could go for that
platform actually more chains I think
that that's a pretty damn good idea
David sir at this point I wouldn't be
surprised if one of these Maga speakers
quote accidentally drops the hard R
these people are Extreme as hell anyway
thanks for all you do David appreciate
it great it wouldn't surprise me either
it would not surprise me either that is
for damn sure
let's see oh let's just make sure we're
not missing it no we're not okay Trump
still hasn't arrived fine
um I'm not going to do Russell Brand
right now we did the Marjory Taylor
green clip we did the uh Ted Nugent clip
a lot of the same Clips here
let's see what else we have
attacking Ukraine that's a common one
casual homophobia from Matt Gates
wearing his Red Jacket let's see sure
sure the crafts bench they've got Pete
butter judge as their fake construction
worker and Elizabeth Warren is their
fake Indian
oh oh my God
that is some that is some hard cringe
that is hard hard cringe
a lot of Florida voters like that though
they voted they voted to re-elect Gates
which is really something else huh
thanks to Dave Schmidt for the twitch
Prime subscription absolutely love it
uh let's listen to a little more from
Gates
president Trump has come to our rescue
before and he's ready now
only Donald Trump could have rescued us
from Hillary Clinton
[Applause]
Taylor Loren says hi David please give a
shout out to my babes Josh He worships
you almost as much as he worships me oh
God we are huge fans and drink your
coffee daily we love it we haven't sold
coffee for years
what do you think Taylor's drinking
anybody have any idea
we drink your coffee daily I don't even
know what that's about do I have coffee
I don't even know what product that is
nobody knows yeah that's weird
Prime huh
maybe somebody's selling
coffee under my name or something
anyway there's uh from Mia also going by
Taylor Lauren appreciate it very much
thank you great to see you we have a uh
an historic Super Chat from San Sam Dean
coming in at 200 Australian dollars
which must be at least like five USD
says good day made have you seen the
crazy insane Trump's knives promotion on
right side broadcasting just Bonkers I'm
just saying your sense of personal free
indelible unchallengeable Independence
can't look past the fact that the
political party you oppose is handing
out free knives I have not seen that
I have not seen that
but it is pretty compelling I'm not
gonna lie I would be interested in a
trump knife here is apparently live
video from Trump's plane I guess flying
to Waco I don't know
um it's all very very weird and here we
are standing by that's Eric Balling on
the left increasingly looking like his
face is Clay very weird really really
odd stuff but uh
we are we are of course continuing to
stand by I want to say a huge thank you
to our great friend Desiree Delong
Desiree just gifted a subscription on uh
to my website at joinpakman.com folks if
you want a free membership do not email
me I said this last time three people
emailed me we just delete them do not
email me
for the free memberships you fill out
the form
at
davidpackman.com free membership do not
email me okay the email will just be
deleted but today's coupon code is
indeed indict all right let's look at a
couple more Clips here we looked at the
picture of Matt Gates uh let's see
here's how the rally started
[Music]
I'm telling you the whole world sucks
and America's catching up but here in
Waco Texas with the real kickers
this don't suck at all
[Applause]
by the way I hate I I know that there's
some people who also say David
um Ted Nugent's politics are terrible
but his music is good
I've always hated his music it's just I
find it vile I really do it's just it's
not for me it is not for me
uh let's see what else we have
pillow attacking desanctus what's going
on right now people also ask me about
Trojan Horse Ron DeSantis okay
let me I can sit here and go on and on
about that but he pretty much uh done
himself in last week with his comments
about our great president being arrested
and
and the best thing he could do would be
endorse Donald Trump tomorrow morning
that would make sense wouldn't it
remember pillow at one point predicted
that DeSantis would endorse Trump the
next day of course it didn't happen as
I'm sure you probably know by now
earlier I played a clip for you of Ted
Nugent referring to Vladimir zolenski
the Ukrainian president as a homosexual
weirdo Ed Henry said that that's what a
lot of Americans feel I have not heard a
single comment ever about zelenski being
gay but Ed Henry says it's just the
voice of the people exactly his remarks
amazing about zielinski and I want my
money back he is channeling what a lot
of Americans feel Eden does that Henry
sound drunk
did is it just me or does Henry sound
completely wasted
that is really odd
some people agree oh but I've never
heard him sound like this exactly his
remarks amazing about zielinski and I
want my money back he is channeling what
a lot of Americans feel not just at the
rallies but I suspect some of the royal
Americans will talk to in a minute and
people at home who are streaming this
live who are undoubtedly cheering along
with tedious and when he Ted jujin
oh boy it's going to be a long night
folks I am uh I'm a little horrified by
what awaits us today thanks to Heigl for
the twitch Prime subscription
uh Ted Nugent did a moment of silence
for the alleged terrorists from January
6th you're right it's a moment of
silence for the political prisoners in
the gulags of Washington DC gulags
because of Jack booted thugs in our own
government
right it's a moment of silence that's
sort of weird I'm not gonna lie uh all
right let's see what else we have here
um the homosexual weirdo stuff
continuing
see what else we have
Marjorie Taylor green asked about the
Trump indictment you see this
see this President Trump an attacking
politically attacking the top Republican
presidential candidate of 2024. I'm
telling you right now here's a bet Alvin
Bragg does not have charges against him
for indicting Trump if it ever happens
now once we cross this line in this
country America is over as you know it
and yeah all right I don't agree with
that here is a trump fan being
interviewed by Ed Henry
and uh here's what they had to say and
he believes in
in snapshots of with some numbers across
their chest yeah we need to lock them up
yeah no doubt about it quick last
thought from you really high level
conversation happening there in Vero
Beach Florida Mr Spencer says via Super
Chat I'm a teacher in Utah saw a poster
in a classroom that had a picture and
quote from Chomsky attributed to gnome
Chomp ski where is the P coming from I
always wonder where the P comes from in
Chomsky and I've never gotten a
satisfactory answer ever ever ever
standing by for Donald Trump due in
eight minutes in Waco Texas we'll listen
to a few other
comments from the Trump rally here's an
interview with your average Trump
supporter
the most beautiful dresses oh yeah so
you get to be family here and we get to
communicate and
um hey it's a family reunion Trump
brings family together right we want
America to be great again save Empower
and we need Trump back for 2024 no
matter what
no matter what is a scary sort of little
add-on there I have to say that doesn't
I don't like that very very much that
scares me
uh let's see what else we have
from the rally in Waco Texas and yes we
we are on the ground at the rally we
will have interviews for you from the
rally on Monday uh probably Monday maybe
Tuesday we'll we will see
let's see what else we have here
um
woman at the Trump rally talks about the
Waco cult tragedy okay same this looks
like the same woman we just looked at a
clip of
Waco Texas
anytime we're going to be
going to be what happened
like satin and silk 30 years ago 30
years ago uh here in Waco uh the
massacre of Waco
is someone telling her what to say it
sounds like someone's off camera telling
her what to say
uh and the tragic what happened when
Janet Reno and the FBI came over to the
compound not that he was not he should
have been prosecuted he was evil and
what he was doing to those to those
women and kids however
the FBI and Jennifer anybody noticing
those strange pauses almost like
someone's telling her what to say it's
very weird
and everyone in the compound but that's
another story it's been 10 years 30
years to go since then but today it's
been 10 20 or 30 years depending on when
during the 64 second clip you talked to
her when I hear to celebrate
um Donald J Trump or his first rally he
chose the greatest country in the world
God's country the greatest country in
the world where what country is he going
to have the rally and he's running in
the United States yes maybe Russia okay
I see I see people in the chat okay and
we're here in Waco and meeting many many
many
sounds sounds quite a
quite interesting very very interesting
um it's all a little bit scary I have to
say Sam says seriously if you check out
free Trump knife then put a dot then
come you'll see it's insane best of luck
with the stream mate thanks Sam I'll
check it out after the stream I
appreciate that always appreciate Sam's
support Charlie asks are the Maga hats
getting larger they seem cartoonishly
large lately chain supply yeah
um the the mega hats are getting bigger
let's see what this message is
no audio oh hold on I muted it since
with your help we will Master the
Democrats game of ballot harvesting and
we will win back the White House from
Joe Biden and the people that are
destroying our country they're
absolutely destroying America thank you
very much
okay
very uh important advertisement there
thanks to Sheila Owen who just signed up
and gifted a subscription on my website
joinpakman.com also a big thank you to
DJ White Rabbit for the twitch Prime
subscription you're number 13 today I
appreciate that let's listen a little
bit live to the sights and sounds of the
Trump rally in Waco Texas
today and as you can see some of the
people are starting to stand up
president Trump was expected to take the
stage at five o'clock his playing Trump
force one has not landed yet so people
are standing up looking toward the skies
waiting for that massive jet to fly over
so they're saying they're running a few
minutes late so it should be any minute
now that President Trump will be making
a fly over the crowd here in Waco Texas
yeah and again they're standing up here
waiting to see the president we've had a
great lineup of speakers the crowd right
now all right so that's what's happening
there and then uh Newsmax currently in
commercial so we're watching all of it
very closely big thank you to Joan
Wilson for signing up at joinpakman.com
and giving away a membership I really do
appreciate that let's look at a few
other clips from the from the event
um as very very soon this rally is going
to be starting a guy with a Confederate
flag sweatshirt at the rally certainly
no surprise there uh the pope wearing uh
the pope wearing puffy coat is this for
real I love this wow that is a statement
right there folks that is a hell of a
coat
uh I have this thing in black but uh
very surprised to see the uh we need a
fit check on the Pope
wow that is that'll make you think
um
okay something about Silicon Valley Bank
here I want to read you an article from
Fox News just so you're up to date and
I'm going to follow that up with a press
release that Ted Cruz sent out a little
bit more in detail
you don't know House Republicans are
demanding a Biden to answer on Chinese
ties to the collapsed silica this woman
can barely read whatever she's been fed
I guess it's a Fox News article she's
trying to read off of the delivery and
the syntax very confused very very
confused it's actually like when Trump
reads off of the prompter Republicans
are demanding a Biden to answer on
Chinese ties to the collapse Silicon
Valley silicone this was news to me
silicone that's even better oh God the
silicone Bank
you know we're having a real problem
plastic surgeons simply can't get what
they need for surgeries because of the
collapse of the silicone bank it's
really a tragedy that's that's it really
is sad
um all right let's see what else we've
got here a guy at the rally wants to do
a citizens arrest of Alvin Bragg for
itself arrest Alvin Bragg uh Alvin Bragg
is overstepping his boundaries we the
people are calling for the arrest of
Alvin this guy's got legal scholar
written all over him I believe it if he
says there's some funny business there
in the DA's office I believe it then
brag four crimes of treason election
interference I don't even know if that's
a crime but election interference
obstruct that's the key line in this
entire thing folks I don't even know if
that's a crime that is fundamentally the
that's the critical moment from this
interview production of Justice even
lying to a grand jury Trump done nothing
wrong we're here to show support for the
greatest president ever Donald Trump
arrest Alvin Bragg you know in South
Carolina you could do citizens arrests
right so if Alvin Bragg ever comes to
South Carolina arrest them arrest them
we the people arrest there you go that's
some interesting legal scholarship by
the way they complain about novel uh
novel uh uh uh legal interpretations
from Alvin Bragg that sounds like a
pretty novel legal interpretation myself
I have to tell you all right big thank
you to Oliver Hernandez who just dumped
in five gifted subscriptions via YouTube
really very much appreciate that huge
thank you to Andy Robison and Jason
sickmeyer with two memberships on my
website folks let's do this once and
only once okay
genuinely speaking we depend on your
support for everything the podcast the
YouTube channel the radio show which we
just give away the TV show which we just
give away the Spanish dubbed channel
that we're doing all of this different
stuff okay
contrary to what Alex Jones might tell
you we're not funded by George Soros
we're really just funded by people who
sign up at joinpakman.com I would love
for you to sign up today this is so easy
the coupon code indict above my head
saves you big money you can do yearly or
you can do monthly I don't care I just
want you involved I I would love it for
George Soros to fund the show he just
doesn't okay you type in indict and you
must spell it correctly and then I'll be
I don't want to overstate this insane
discount
but it is crazy okay everybody who signs
up your name will pop up here I'll thank
you it's a really really great thing you
all know that YouTube Revenue has gone
to zero sometimes Facebook Revenue has
gone to zero we've been banned from tick
tocks we've been blocked by by
everything okay the way we control our
programming is by dividing up our
support among so many of you so no one
big funder or company come come in and
say David
you better say this or you better say
that or whatever the case may be uh
really appreciate everybody who's
already signed up and we will we will
continue thanking people the website is
working you can also sign up via twitch
it all counts we're going for 100 today
and uh what is the coupon code it's in
diet the coupon code is above my head I
don't know if I was unclear about that
but the coupon code is indict you can
get banned on Tick Tock for literally
anything yes you can that's absolutely
the case that is absolutely the case you
certainly can big thank you to Jody
Hansen on the website appreciate that
you're number 22 today let's look at a
couple of other Clips here here is
someone with a uh Trump or death
flag and a let's go brand and flag on
their Jeep very cool
uh really really
Alpha very manly you can tell
guy at a trump rally has won multiple
bets okay let's see
yeah because we've got an ongoing bet uh
he owes me like three or four rounds of
golf because he said Trump was going to
be installed in March after the election
and it was August and then by the end of
the year oh this is this is Rich guys
here and yeah and I said I don't think
so Tommy there's you know there's uh
there's a constitution and and Tommy wow
this is maybe the one voice of reason at
the rally the guy in the middle
he's like you know what Trump's not
getting reinstated we have this thing
called the Constitution that is amazing
and do you think president Trump's going
to be back in office he is do you think
he's going to be back in office I think
he'll be definitely elected if not
something happened this year I believe
how would something happen this year it
is you know at a certain point you've
got to start to feel bad for these
people except they are such a disgrace
and damaging to the country but wouldn't
you think at this point after losing all
of these bets to Tommy
or or rather he is Tommy losing bets
don't you think he would just go he's
not going to be back unless he wins in
2024 I would respect the guy if he was
able to say that uh but seemingly unable
to seemingly or unwilling I guess I
don't know all right folks we are seeing
some pretty serious membership dumps
happening here thanks to Marjorie Milner
Donald Bradford and Mark Byrne they all
just signed up on my website putting us
at 25.
a couple super chats coming in here
thanks to Crystal great to see you
crystal Kenneth this is David sir I
would give my good right arm to see one
of these Maga weirdos try and explain
what a citizen's arrest actually is I
would love to see that myself
thanks to Spud
Daniel says signed up for a free Pac-Man
show subscription at a mall kiosk was
that not legit gave the guy my credit
card info folks you cannot get free
memberships at Amal kiosk you can only
get the free memberships at
davidpackman.com free membership so do
not fall for it if you are at a mall
thanks to Brian Yates Brian Gross and
rosemary sneddon new members 26 27 and
28 today this is really the start of the
2024 campaign it is going to be wild
just as a reminder to everybody I have a
hard out at 7 30 Eastern I've got a
friend's birthday party tonight I just
want to make sure everybody's aware of
that but we are expecting the rally to
start very soon here's a woman at the
rally selling a book containing letters
from the alleged January 6th
insurrectionists
has hundreds of American gulag
Chronicles it's called letters from the
actual prisoners tell us a little bit
more sure that's correct this book was
compiled uh so that we could see what
they're going through because what
they're going through is horrific it's
truly horrific and they go in great
detail about what is happening to them
and and the proceeds of this book
support the calls but also they're get
them there right yeah
that's a pretty sad uh book I have to
tell you it is not a not a great book uh
welcome to Chef Ramsey via twitch has
been subscribed for seven months it
actually has a picture of Gordon Ramsay
but I can't imagine that's the real
Gordon Ramsay right anybody know is
Gordon Ramsay on Twitch
kind of interesting if you were
any ideas
let's see six month subscriber
has commented once
can I get that Obama sound bite that I
for some reason I don't think
that Gordon Ramsay would be here asking
for this
hmm
probably not if anybody knows anything
about that let me know because it sounds
sounds pretty pretty compelling I'm not
gonna lie all right
um here is a woman at the Trump rally
who is a South African Maga preacher
amazing what's your name and where are
you from my name is lindian hopley and I
am a South African Mega preacher
she says it like that's a known thing
I'm a South African Mega preacher oh
okay cool
interesting no could you live in South
Africa now I'm living in America uh
because God actually told me that
there's a Revival Coming to America
logical totally sensible thing to say
and in the dream that I had president
Trump was in it so I'm all about just
praying for this country and seeing God
get his full reward so this is something
you could treat psychiatric medicine
would treat this a number of different
ways that's just the reality I mean
think take a step back for a second and
think about what she is saying she was
living in in South Africa everything was
fine God came to her in a dream and said
you need to go to the United States and
preach about Trump because there's a
Revival
you would go and I say this um I am not
making a diagnosis but many
psychiatrists in my family and in my
circles if if she went to them and said
that she would probably be medicated and
it would it would probably be well
there's a number of different
pharmaceutical approaches that you could
take that's amazing where do you live
here in the United States I'm in DFW so
we came down with a trump train with all
the Texans you know going crazy all the
trucks just honking and going wild it's
so great to see how many patriots there
are and so many supporters of just this
great movement did they run anybody off
the road for having a Biden sign
fantastic and what is it about President
Trump that you love so much
well to be honest I just started
dreaming about him I am you know I have
a totally normal totally normal guys fit
a gift and the Lord stopped oh wait hold
on she said she had a prophetic gift
well to be honest I just started
dreaming about him I am you know I have
a prophetic gift and the Lord started is
this an actress
could this the only possibility other
than serious mental illness is that this
is an actress right and that this is all
just to make make Trump supporters look
crazy
people are divided as to what this is
jeez I'm speaking to me about him and
and totally not
pushed or I travel around the world
world you had me fooled
he said despite the fact that I'm
dripping in Maga gear and moved halfway
across the world to go to a rally near
some some Sani cans uh I'm actually not
a political person at all right and
don't hide it underneath a basket so I
was a wild party girl and had an
encounter with no you were I I don't see
it
loved about this is that I actually in
one of my dreams I sat in front of
President Trump and I knew he was giving
me something it sounds actually says
prison Trump some type of job you know I
was kind of like and I said to I'm the
Lord in my dream I said I don't want to
lose my Ministry for this like this guy
and he said you want to lose your
ministry I just want you to partner with
him for a season so I knew that haven
was backing him
um that he's like Osiris and where God
used someone in business to to further
his kingdom and psych hold and quick
quick quick would be my recommation
there folks very very quick before it
gets worse all right thank you to some
great people who are signing up on my
website folks the generosity this is
unbelievable thanks to Caroline
genshimer
Amanda Bernard Alex marcusines
Joseph Cerrone Caroline genshimer with
another membership wait a second
two memberships okay I hope that's not a
glitch Jeffrey Parsons Leslie Gasper
Sue Dunford Andrea McIntyre Chad Pearson
Joseph notariani and Jacqueline crusore
or crusoor uh 10 additional members
really appreciate that very very much
appreciate that let's listen to just
like one voicemail one voicemail
um I just wanted to uh call and
apologize to you man um I've been trying
to you know give you some information
and stuff but I didn't I didn't really
click to me that you were just
um Pro establishment media and the
government paid media and that narrative
right the government's paying yeah the
government's paying me there you go
nothing you know
Trump is anti-establishment Boston's
anti-establishment and I just felt that
all the media was supposed to be you
know keep the government distracted and
keep people in check but man you just
just beat the drum just carry the water
for all these people and
um I was just like pissing up a rope
trying to talk to you because he was
pissing up a rope
what you know you're just gonna beat the
drum whatever they say whatever news
leak says CNN says
um I haven't seen you once straight from
the company talking point oh God and um
I think that's kind of anyway these are
the folks that are waiting for the
demise of the show
that it typical Eric from Mass is the
classic guy so that's why when people
like cm71 over on Twitch or a folks over
on the website Rebecca Davidson welcome
Rebecca Nick Gutierrez when people like
that sign up as they are doing right now
you're basically saying to Eric from
Mass get the hell out of here
Andrew Crichton Andrew Crichton new
member number 43.
very much appreciate it let's look at a
few super chats here
um why is Trump in Waco there's a new
Netflix series any correlation thank you
David for informing it's roughly the
30-year anniversary since the Waco uh
disaster
and I guess maybe there's some
connection I don't know it's it's
Trump's motives are never completely
clear let's just put it that way okay we
are standing by for Trump's arrival in
Waco Texas running about 12 minutes late
as of right now we are looking at other
clips and elements from the rally
here oh this is so fun okay all right
let me set this up for you
all I'm going to say before we look at
this clip is okay and then you let me
know in the chat
I'm going to play a 19 second clip of
this guy saying that he served in the
Marines
okay after the 19 seconds are done tell
me
do you think he's telling the truth or
do you think he's lying here we go did
you serve I did where where'd you start
Maureen me too what was your mof
I was special oh I see okay
I flew into places okay where were you
dark places where were you stationed I I
uh can't go into detail okay okay this
interview is over okay
liar or truth teller liar or truth
teller what do people think
what do people think
wow a lot of liar fake fake fake Liar
Liar Liar one truth
narcissist Liar Liar almost certainly a
liar
BS most honest person there
loon liar impossible to tell
liar
interesting it's the truth yeah I
honestly I have no idea I'm not even
pretending I'm not even pretending to
have any idea whatsoever big thank you
to Gwen Lombardi signing up with the
coupon code indict your new member
number 44. also a big thank you to brain
matter brain matter is asking if we get
to 100 members will I do a show with
half of my mustache no but if we get to
500 I would if we get to 500 I would uh
all right still no Trump so we can keep
looking at some of these other clips
uh a trump mystery box was brought out
let's talk about something fun real
quick how about a mystery box
Trump Mystery Box whoa that sounds
pretty fun flavor to your house and
what's gonna be inside we really don't
know so if you go to
uh site where you can uh get your Trump
mystery box maybe you can keep it for
yourself somebody should tell her the
website I guess you can keep it for your
family member Easter's coming up throw
it in somebody's basket how would you
like to have something Trump in your
basket yeah there you go uh there's an
idea okay guys so put the the
um wow this is really uh uh just a
horrifying situation J trade says Dear
David thank you so much for reading the
message from my darling Mia we are both
long time fans she lights up my life
like a cup of progressive wake-up call
keep up the great work much love okay so
that's our old old coffee oh and these
folks are in the UK so I can't imagine
they really have our coffee oh by the
way I will be in the UK very very soon
I'm gonna be in London uh going to be in
Cambridge Windsor
uh bath it's going to be quite a trip
quite a trip and thanks to Ariel for the
Super Chat as well very very much
appreciate that all right let's see is
uh so it looks like Trump any moment is
going to arrive hold on that's not
that's the YouTube numbers I don't know
where that came from
um okay let's look at a couple other
interview elements the values with you I
love how you say God first because that
is lacking in this country right now
Veronica thank you so much and yes
Vanessa let me tell you he photobombed
me earlier you may have seen him there
you go that is Vanessa not Veronica just
a little bit of confusion nothing new to
a trump rally here's a guy explaining
why he loves Trump so much what is about
President Trump that you like
um his vision and the fact that he
stands for truth you know
sure sure sure
yeah he stands for true
he stands for truth the only truth that
Trump stands for is this truth essential
everybody stands for those things we all
grew up hearing about truth justice in
the American way right there you go um
he's the kind of person that he leads by
example I mean he shows up at these
rallies he goes out to the restaurants
he meets the people Trump goes to
restaurants I know he went to like a
Wendy's or something but didn't know he
was going to restaurants it's weird
um all right looks like Trump is about
to arrive here thanks to Beth Graham
sligator fantabulous and Ozzy for the
twitch Prime subscriptions welcome
everybody watching on Twitch great to
have you here also folks the we may run
out of memberships tonight
Melissa Fairbanks just signed up
uh Nina Williams Robert Frain chicken
nugget and Pamela Cardinal all signing
up on my website Donald Trump delivering
a message to the crowd let's listen wave
goodbye because Democrats would win
every single election we have to get
smart and that's why our campaign will
fight back and start harvesting ballots
in the states where the left has been
cheating the system and her so he's
saying they're they're going to commit
election fraud what ballots will only
come from legal registered voters who
are American citizens with your help we
will Master the Democrats game of ballot
harvesting and we will win back the
White House from Joe Biden and the
people that are destroying our so it
seems like what he's setting up is
listen since they cheated in 2020 we're
gonna cheat in 2024.
[Music]
we got a little update and you guys got
to hear a little bit more about what
president Trump just said we can say he
will be here soon so that is that's our
update for you we're hoping it's like 20
minutes yeah so if you have to go to the
bathroom go now go get ready because
he's coming
but oh my God getting very crass there
uh all right let's see big thank you to
Yannick Lajoie
as well as Bonnie Squibb
and Melissa Fairbanks with the website
memberships let's keep taking a look at
uh oh there's like a lot a lot of
different things going on actually so
let's let's continue
um
here's a guy who who's threatening not
to vote for Ted Cruz if Ted Cruz won't
defend Trump more will not go after
president Trump I call Ted Cruz's office
and I told them that if they don't start
speaking up for Donald Trump then when I
go to vote I'm on a vote for president
Trump alone and walk away wow
wow
that's a pretty big deal
they got to be careful about that
um the guy who claims to be a marine
says
make all migrants U.S citizens so that
they'll become Republicans interesting
idea we have probably 150 new people
since I think Trump should give them all
away to citizenship since they're here
let Trump do that right steal the votes
from the Democrats
there you go a political strategy okay
here is the ad for Trump knives that
everybody's been telling me about
limited edition collectible knife in
honor of today's rally again that's free
trumpknife.com there you go 250
collectible knives just cover the cost
of shipping that's less than ten dollars
add this as a patriotic knife to your
collection and keep America great with
this collectible piece we are spreading
Trump's reach and support through the
limited time promotion we're spreading
Trump's reach through knives you can
keep it for yourself you can give it as
a gift again hold on to it as your own
as time passes more and more Trump
related memorabilia could surge in value
yeah cheap Trump knives might be which
you can get for nine dollars May soon be
extremely valuable extremely valuable
um how is this real life seriously folks
how I I might have to retire at this
rate uh thanks to Seven Dust for the uh
Super Chat although I don't really
understand it
um Laura says first live one in a long
time that I have been awake for great to
have you here Laura from Canada great to
see you as always thanks Jax for the
twitch Prime subscription You're Number
57 today newest member on the website is
Tiffany Ayala Tiffany Ayala number 58
folks we are here with the coupon code
indict
it's working everybody relax the coupon
code is fine let's do like one or two
more voicemails just to see what's going
on
hey David I'm here at this uh Waco
garbage
uh standing outside
do you know there's only maybe
500 maybe
550 people at this rally this is a
freaking joke I am not a Donald Trump
supporter by any means
this is hilarious I'm not saying a word
to these okay whoa whoa I just saw I
just read ahead and this guy starts to
get a little blue so we're going to get
away from it all right let me see if I
have anything else here for everybody
real quick as far as voicemails are
concerned uh uh
oh some people are some people are
cheering and some people are upset that
when I go to a hotel and I find one of
the Gideon Bibles I put it out in the
hallway like a room service tray here's
one caller weighing in on that I tend to
agree with you on these Gideon Bibles in
these hotel rooms you know what I would
do though
I would probably leave the Bible in
there but I put my version
of the Bible next to it that's a lot of
work yeah I don't think I'm going to be
doing that that's just now I'm writing
now I've got to bring a pen and I just
put it out in the hallway that's that's
my move
uh forecast for this evening stochastic
terrorism with a Chance of personal
threats buy a trump knife and well you
know what to do says Mr Scott via Super
Chat yeah let's hope that Trump doesn't
incite violence at tonight's rally
although it seems like a uh
it seems likely that there will be
violence incited that's for sure
let's see what else we have from the
rally
a guy with a huge flag
all right
DeSantis talking about his wife that's
kind of interesting let's see he's a
great mother she's a great first lady I
mean she's really the whole package and
you know there's a picture that I have
2019 inauguration 2023 sitting at the
desk same pose she's prettier and 23
than she was in 2019 and she had a kid
she went through four years of this
nonsense and she beat breast cancer and
how do you end up being prettier after
four years of that he's a great
uh just dripping dripping with Charisma
as you can tell hey by the way it was
brought to my attention that Ron
DeSantis used to pronounce his last name
Ron DeSantis and it was only a few years
ago I don't know how many of you heard
about this here's my question okay and
and I'm not kidding around with this
this is a serious question what stranger
to do at age 40 okay
completely do a 180 on your politics
like Dave Rubin supposedly right do a
complete 180 on your politics at age 40.
like you never knew you were actually a
right winger or to change the
pronunciation of your own last name
which one is stranger
what do people think
the last name is stranger hmm
a lot of people saying the last name
that's interesting
last name huh wow
the last name okay yeah fine yeah
there's all these videos of him saying
Ron D santis let me see if I can find it
I might actually start saying my last
name Parkman soon but uh Ron DeSantis
last name
pronunciation it's a very weird thing
let's see here
okay it's a YouTube short that I've got
about this from Midas Touch let's take a
look at it
bony Ron desantises it appears he
changed the pronunciation of his own
last name over the past few years to
better align with what the polls were
telling him voters preferred I'm not
kidding watch this I'm Ron DeSantis I am
Ron DeSantis I am Ron DeSantis this is
Governor Ron DeSantis hello this is
Governor Ron DeSantis wishing everyone a
Merry Christmas
is it all fake is everything just a lie
with these people I don't know guys it's
um so he there's actually two changes he
went from D to duh and he used to say
santis and now it's sanus Ron DeSantis
now it's Ron DeSantis
Ron DeSantis
I need I need a new last name folks I
really do think I do
a big thank you to Dominic Bonacci as
well as Luciano Quinones
and Stanley minarik great to see you
Stan uh gifting some memberships people
doing all sorts of stuff thanks to Adam
lab over on Twitch really appreciate
that
um I am think I I can't stop thinking
about that Trump knife
I kind of really am drawn to it I don't
know
it's just like it's in my head I can't
get away from the idea of getting one it
sounds really good let's see if we have
anything else from the rally here we
might be kind of getting to the end we
got the guy with the flag and
uh
this is very early all right so it seems
we kind of got to the beginning of of
the rally let's see if there's anything
new everybody yeah a lot of people
really focusing in they're giving away
250 of the knives
free Trump knife oh I guess it's like
you pay shipping and handling sort of
thing
and they've got the flag painted on it
and everything well nice knife I mean
seems pretty nice I don't know
uh oh one more clip this person knows
the truth about 911. did you get my poem
your friend away just make sure to let
me know you notice I have some more
thighs now
more thighs what does that mean anybody
know what that means
she has more thighs
I don't know what these people are
talking about
it's a good man right here
so yeah I put on a little way in jail oh
she did need more thoughts oh it was
nice she's talking about she put weight
on in her thighs that's interesting wow
um I'm here this is a January 6 rioter
for people who might not know live and
I'm well and so you know one of the
reasons why I couldn't walk down the
scaffolding scaffolding that's an
interesting pronunciation too it's like
it you know in New England some people
say scallops and some people say
scallops but I've never heard
scaffolding and Scaffolding I've only
heard scaffolding it's the fact I know
the truth not far too many things as I
wrote a poem after September 11th Paul
we're ready to fight General Flynn
signed it for me Milani gave it a heart
on Facebook my base commander had me
read it in Baghdad Iraq I remember the
ceremony September 11 2007. so down at
the bottom I just changed this okay down
at the bottom all right so she has a she
has a poem
um a user on Twitch is explaining the
knife thing to me you pay shipping and
handling the knife is just under four
inches on the blade which allows in
Florida specifically to carry it and not
be an illegal deadly weapon ah over four
inches is banned in Florida I did not
know that that is not information that I
had I have to admit there is the Trump
plane a Boeing 757 30 or 40 years old it
is back up and running after a very very
difficult period during which Trump was
begging for money to fix his plane
folks uh we are moments away as Newsmax
very very poor video quality so we'll
get over here to right side broadcasting
seems to be able to keep it up and
running uh I want to say a huge thank
you Stanley minarik is just gifting
subscription after subscription Wesley
Taylor as well big thank you to Gustavo
urquiza and Wesley Taylor dumping in a
few more memberships next membership
will be number 69 out of 100 and we
really do appreciate that how long will
Trump's speech be Trump's speeches are
really long they are castro-like and I
expect it to go an hour and 40 minutes
or so something like an hour and 40
minutes would be my guess it's on
average how long Trump speaks it's if he
just read through the teleprompter which
of course remember Obama was a loser for
using Obama but Trump uses a prompter as
well it would probably be a 50-minute
speech but between the non-securators
and the tangents glitches and repeating
stories
uh it's probably you know going to be
more like about an hour and 40 minutes
or so something like that
um let's listen to
let's listen to another
voicemail or two just while we're here
oh wait hold on let's listen to their
commentary about Trump's plane yeah he
he's so good so they're back behind us
right now dude completing their
completing the flyover and they're going
to eventually taxi right over here and
park behind us so you will see that
she's explaining basically how planes
land so so basically it's just like the
plane's gonna fly around a little bit
eventually it will land on the runway
then it'll taxi and then Trump will get
off whoa pretty fascinating stuff that
was symbolic
and it is exciting like everyone's been
talking about wanting home for our
nation and wanting to know here's
something sort of interesting a couple
people wrote to me and said about the
growth of this uh YouTube thing right
side broadcasting and they're on Rumble
as well some people wrote to me and said
David you're in the business what do you
think that these anchors could possibly
be getting paid by right side
broadcasting I honestly have no idea and
the reason I have no idea
is that depending on who funds right
side broadcasting they may be
subsidizing the salaries of these people
Way Beyond like what the market would
suggest they should make based on the
revenues and and so on and so forth so I
really have I really couldn't say
I would doubt it's over
180 a year like at the most I think if
if you know they were very well funded
and right side broadcasting was sort of
generous
made like I think 180 would be like the
top top top
but
I really have no idea I genuinely have
no clue
um it's extraordinarily opaque to me
very very opaque
uh looks like they're getting out of the
way for the big Landing here which is uh
going to happen momentarily
um
someone someone's here okay
I don't know who that is big thank you
to Kyoko awaya Tommy horse will Stanley
minarik Wesley Taylor and Stanley
minarik for another three give another
five gifted subscriptions what what is
happening right now what is what is this
[Music]
oh this is that lunatic who goes to the
rallies and does like Jesus paintings
look at this oh my God is she having a
manic episode
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
s are made
[Music]
is this is it a is it a drawing of trump
is that what's going on
[Applause]
[Music]
it's from the color of like what looks
to be the skin being orange I assume
it's Trump
[Music]
[Applause]
I'd recommend decaf at least trying it
okay
um Wesley Taylor thanks for the gifted
subscription very much appreciated folks
if you're just joining us and you're
wondering how to get these free
subscriptions that people are gifting
it's very easy
go to davidpackman.com free membership
davidpackman.com free membership okay
bay photo says hard to believe that
Trump knives pillows and gold coin ads
keep the lights on for right side
broadcasting network I have no idea how
many people get the knives or I
genuinely could not tell you really
couldn't tell you
um
this is looking a little bit grotesque I
have to say
[Music]
[Applause]
by the way you can tell that a big
storyline in Trump's speech today is
going to be the investigation into him
being called a Witch Hunt as evidenced
by all of the Witch Hunt signs that you
can see there uh in the background
um okay couple other things here
let's see what else okay so let me again
I see people asking we are on the ground
we are on the ground in Waco Texas today
with one of our correspondents for their
safety his or her safety I'm not going
to either identify them right now you
know we have a number of correspondents
um I don't want them being sought out
you know their safety is is the top
concern but we are on the ground in Waco
Texas and we will have clips from
interviews with Trump supporters at the
rally
um on the Monday show or on the Tuesday
show depending on how long it takes us
to turn it all around are we still
streaming on Twitch yes we are live on
Twitch right now we are live on Twitch
right now a lot of people asking if the
woman here is having a seizure not to
the best of my knowledge but I am not a
medical professional I believe she's
painting I believe she's it is getting
pretty damn animated I'm going to tell
you though a lot of flailing
uh
my baby daughter flails a lot of time in
like the first hour or two of sleep and
it looks a lot like this except my
daughter doesn't hold paint brushes with
orange you know burnt sienna type paint
on them
it is performative it's like a drummer
you know who is uh
Dear God
this is really this is really a sick
country that's my takeaway here thanks
to thurches for the twitch Prime
subscription you're number 75 as Donald
Trump's plane is landing about 40
minutes later then the event was
supposed to start folks welcome this is
the first rally for 2023's calendar year
and the first official 2024 campaign
rally there is nothing more poetic than
this as Donald Trump's gaudy plane lands
in front of a crowd of mouth-watering
sycophants who don't know up from down a
woman is either painting or having a
very serious medical episode all
happening at the same time
it's it's like no other country has this
no other country has this combination
um it is it is a cult and if there's any
fitting
if there's any poetic
Fitness to this being held in Waco Texas
on the 30-year anniversary of The Siege
in Waco on the Branch Davidians it is
that there is no greater modern cult
than trumpism and I think that that
makes a lot of sense if you are
disgusted by this and you don't want
Trump's knife and you don't want Mike
pillows or any of that stuff what I
offer to you it's very humble it's not
you know you're not going to be able to
cut anyone up with it or anything like
that but we have this coupon code indict
when you go to my website joinpakman.com
you type in the coupon code when signing
up for a membership and it'll cost you
two bucks a month okay if you have cable
you may not know it but you're giving
Fox News four bucks a month
that true story folks not a joke not
where's my Biden stuff not a joke here
it is bruh but here we go oh God where
is my not a joke give me a break okay
what a stupid son of a I can't
find out a joke in all seriousness
it's just Independent Media okay getting
a membership won't give you a weapon you
can hurt anyone with like the free Trump
knife or anything like that
um but uh I I love when people sign up
and let me thank a few of those folks
our great friend Kyoko from Tokyo as
well as Wesley Taylor Kyoko gifting
another membership Kyoko just gifting
membership after membership also thanks
to Jeffrey Parsons puts us at 81. will I
be rescheduling my trip to Japan I hope
to do that very soon
I hope to do that very soon as soon as
humanly possible is where I would leave
it uh the painting of Donald Trump is
almost done
[Music]
wow
it's really really something really
something there as you can see uh oh boy
Dear God
um
another voicemail okay actually let me I
feel like I'm falling behind on stuff
okay we're up to date on super chats
let's see if we can do
like another voicemail or two oh here's
the Eggman
hey Dave you know how you always say
that um accusations are more like
admissions of guilt pretty much
um I agree with that
um not just in politics well like not
just with politicians goes like regular
people I see this guy all the time that
has a sticker uh dead pedophiles don't
reoffend and straight white male
Republican sticker on his truck straight
white male Republican it makes me think
that guys with this sticker are more
likely to tap a shoe in the airport
bathroom
it just looks like that right Shalom all
right well the Eggman making some very
very strong accusations there which I'm
not going to weigh in on right now uh I
I agree with people
the painting is a good painting the
painting is a good painting the entire
performance and obviously the cult
worship of the orange man is all
disgusting but it's I I can't say it's I
mean listen I can't do anything that
good uh I'll tell you that right now not
afraid to admit it
just the you know the imagery is not for
me
wow but the the also the manic energy of
the artist is making me a little nervous
I don't know if I need the Xanax or
whether she does thanks to Kyle
Tannehill as well as Michael Loomer for
signing up on my website appreciate you
guys pushing us to 83. Donald Trump's
plane has landed
um as it was explained after landing the
plane taxis for people that didn't know
that they made that very clear we are
down to about like 120 by 60 pixel
resolution here over on Newsmax but the
crowd is getting pretty titillated as
you can tell uh very very poor quality
video there the painting is almost done
and I think that's going to be it'll be
good when it's over let me put it that
way let's see if I have any other
voicemails for folks
uh
uh don't know that I have anything I
necessarily want to publicize a lot of
the voicemails are really better to
forward to law enforcement if you know
what I mean
but let me see if I have something
relatively benign
in some sense
I really don't
I have another I have another 20 20
consecutive voicemail screen if you want
to listen to it listen to this
Daniel from Ronkonkoma New York here hey
David
um
to answer your question if
is
okay so they lose their train of thought
on the first voicemail then they call
right back
holy crap
Dave Daniels from Ronkonkoma New York
hey David
I've been seeing that picture for a year
now and
I always feel okay on your promo card at
the end of your show when you say become
a member you get to the the black okay
then calling back again
hey David this is um
Daniel two Kane's blomberg
um
Ronkonkoma New York
um if you ever want to call me you agree
with me whoa whoa okay and we're done
all right we're not gonna do uh We're
not gonna do doxing on the show today
let's move on there were two there were
18 more from that guy
but let's just move on Just for sanity's
sake thanks to guitar God for the twitch
Prime subscription very much appreciate
no guy he was about to give out his
phone number and it just starts to get
a little difficult a little difficult
difficult
uh let's see what else we have here
um
yeah Trump's uh he's about to get off
his plan yeah that's definitely
happening let's see if we can get no
this isn't 720p it's just a terrible
connection that Muse Max's cameras have
see if I can squeeze anything else in
uh yes David this is Mike from
Pennsylvania
I'm currently watching the uh
your live broadcast of this Waco uh
difficult uh with Trump and then this uh
manic ladies on here the manic painters
putting up this from uh portrait I was
just wondering about I would not be
surprised if he comes out and pedals
that thing off to the highest bidder
right and I just I don't know somehow I
get to see that you know
um it's not right here perhaps today
that would actually be interesting to
see Trump auction off that painting
during this event as a donate a campaign
donation that would be pretty I would be
curious actually what it would go for uh
with this crowd Avalanche of spinach
thank you for the twitch Prime
subscription I really do appreciate that
great to see you
great to see you back big thank you to
Carmela Kelly Ginger Hickerson and Shane
siddle I hope I'm pronouncing that
correctly signing up on my website we
are going to hear from Donald Trump
momentarily just a reminder friendly
friendly reminder to everyone I do have
a hard out at 7 30 Eastern uh have a
friend's birthday to go to tonight and
we'll I will stay up until that time
because of the the late start uh with
Trump I can only imagine he will just be
warming up at that point in time and he
will be
nowhere near nowhere near the end of his
speech uh other voicemails are coming in
hey David Peter from Milwaukee here just
want to give my thoughts on Trump and
Waco
I guess if he were to call for political
violence doing it in Waco kinda makes
sense it's kind of like in their eyes
the underdog being attacked by the man
yeah these are guns to take it back so
absolutely
it's just a little bit too on the nose I
don't know what are your thoughts it's
very on the nose it's very on the nose I
I completely agree with that voicemail
uh it's almost too obvious that you go
to Waco and then call for violence
against the current government which
they see as Biden of course they're not
understanding that most government
employees are not political and it's
just people doing a job
and trying to do the best job they can
and you know feed their family for lack
of a better term the artist is
continuing looks like she must be close
to done here
[Music]
she may be the most well-known Maga
artist I don't and I don't know any
other Maga artists so I would say she
probably is
[Music]
and I can't
wow the cult is getting really really uh
fired up
thanks to richbird Nation for the twitch
Prime subscription your number 89 today
big thank you to Nina Williams as well
as Bill Beebe
who are numbers 90 and 91 folks we may
get to 100 at the stroke of that crazy
song playing that Trump pretends to like
when he gets off the plane
which would be pretty remarkable I have
to tell you
um
she should rap I think it's time for for
the artist to rap
[Music]
really you can't even see the door the
best view
she must not have any idea what people
at home are seeing right now
[Music]
the audience has began to chant for him
the audience has begun
it is amazing how they timed it so that
she finished her painting right as he's
ready to walk out
she's so good is she gonna trash it now
follow her on Instagram and her website
she has all the links there on Instagram
she just has such an amazing story of
how she got started and to see the work
that she does yeah we'll we'll look into
that a little bit later maybe thanks to
Jay tandaway for gifting five
subscriptions via twitch and also a big
thank you to Roy Thorpe for signing up
at joinpakman.com putting us at 97. if
you're just joining us Donald Trump in
Waco Texas running about 50 minutes late
typical for Donald Trump I will be here
with you until 7 30 and then I have a
prior commitment we are expecting
um a lot of lies here as well as
incitement to violence if Trump were to
be arrested this is happening in Waco
Texas on roughly the 30-year anniversary
of The Siege on Waco uh by the I believe
it was ATF and subsequently FBI took
over by the way I will mention this
again if you're curious about what
happened in Waco 30 years ago the great
non-fiction writer Jeff Gwynn recently
published a book I think in January
called Waco about The Siege I recently
finished the book very interesting book
If you're looking for another book
because you already read that one
I'm currently reading the book endurance
about Ernest shackleton's
um Voyage X expedition to Antarctica in
1915 and 1916 I believe are the years so
for people looking for some non-fiction
uh books you can check that out as far
as fiction is concerned I did start
reading at the recommendation of many of
you the expanse I I picked up the first
book The expanse
um I've seen the One season of the
series and I actually have interviewed
on the show one of the
um co-authors of the books and I never
read the books but many of you said the
books are really good
the show is good it's fine there's a
Sci-Fi show but I have to say I'm about
150 pages in and the book is really
quite good I'm finding myself looking
forward to reading it every night a
couple super chats coming in Mr Scott
says pretty certain the artist on stage
is auditioning to be Trump's courtroom
sketch artist for the coming years that
would be an interesting job for her
Alex says my family used to buy art from
a local artist in Florida we went back
recently there was Maga art all over the
shop we won't support her anymore well
that is you're right Alex that is your
speech
thanks to AJ Scorpia Nick Verna oh hey
Nick says any chance the artist is a
progressive and writes Trump lost in
2020 on the bottom that would be
interesting and my guess is it would
slip by a lot of the people uh at the
rally
they just they may not pay attention to
those little details this is my uh my
belief we are standing by for Donald
Trump soon to be an hour late based on
the original schedule
uh let's see what's happening
[Music]
so seemingly having some kind of delay
feedback issue with the audio and of
course I always hope for audio problems
at Trump rallies
[Music]
[Applause]
and our incredible oh these people don't
know what the hell they're doing the
deal that included the largest
agricultural
is worth of our farm product that may be
the best one but I think Eric did not
like
they lived up I used to check it every
week are they buying are they buying
there you go folks there you go thanks
to Lauren samanko for gifting a
subscription on my website you're number
98 today uh I I keep seeing this
question in the chat
how long will this go
we never know it's starting an hour late
often it's like an hour 40 that Trump
will speak
so we'll you know we'll just have to
wait and see and is he going to do all
the hits meaning lying the entire time I
am sure
I'm I am absolutely sure that that is of
course the plan uh let's see if I have
anything else as far as voicemails are
concerned a lot of sadly low quality
voicemails lately
and there's a lot we have
voicemails I haven't seen here's Trump
let's see if I can squeeze in one more
uh
let's see
hockey man what a man what up my
guy Pac-Man how's it going how's the kid
I'm taking care of one myself uh
congrats being a dad oh is this the same
I think this is the San Antonio troll on
to the topic my friend
um oh God you know I gotta you know I
gotta rib gear bit you sewing out last
week
uh to troll is going to get arrested
no no no no I said Trump is claiming
he's going to get arrested
that is the San Antonio troll I'm
basically done with that so we can move
on welcome to Thomas Rule and new member
number 99 folks are we going to be stuck
at 99 instead of 100 before Trump speaks
I feel like we are and that's kind of a
bummer oh Trump's saluting very proudly
[Music]
[Applause]
I can't put my finger on what's wrong
with the audio at the rally but
something is wrong with the audio at the
rally I can't exactly tell what it is
um Jerry Boswell thanks for the Super
Chat
[Music]
yeah it's not exactly a delay and
someone in the chat is saying that it's
a phasing problem that that's the it's
an issue of phasing you know I once went
to a um
I went to what was it it was a a
Matisyahu show Matisyahu's former
bassist Stu a big friend of the show and
we went to dinner while like the next
band was playing I think it was 311 and
we we were at a restaurant like a block
away you could hear the music but it
sounded like this and Stu said it's out
of phase so that may actually be exactly
what's going on
oh by the way we got okay the big thank
you to Luciano Quinones for gifting
another membership putting us at 100 and
people are just dumping in memberships
like crazy blueberry babe and Susanna
Sterling Lana and Jay tandoway putting
us at 104. ladies and gentlemen we did
it we're gonna go for 200 but let's
listen to what Donald Trump has to say I
predict complaints about either the Heat
or the sunlight which are really really
common with this guy number one song on
iTunes Amazon
featuring president Donald J Trump and
the j6 choir
[Music]
what the hell is going on
oh my God is this a choir of the alleged
terrorists
is this a song written by the alleged
insurrectionist is that what they're
playing here
[Music]
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America
oh no
to our International viewers I'm really
sorry
that this fruitcake is getting a little
nutty
[Music]
and to the Republic
for which it stands
it would be genuinely funny if we
weren't laughing to avoid crying
[Music]
so I've been critical before because
many of you come into my chat and you
start saying David this is not orwellian
this is not Orwell I'm sorry you say
this is orwellian this is orwellian this
is orwellian and I explain to you it's
not really orwellian it's more Huxley
and out of Aldous huxley's Brave New
World this has a more orwellian feel I
will admit
[Music]
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
thank you
I'm gonna try this stream because I
think it might be better if not we'll
bail okay
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
well thank you very much okay this
stream is like three pixels so let's
just try this one instead it was Taylor
Swift
number three was Molly Cyrus Molly Cyrus
well we have our moment and that tells
you that our people love those people
they love those people and it's an honor
to be here I say hello Texas a big hello
to Texas we had tremendous
victories in
season and it's great to be back
Incredibles to thousands of proud
hard-working American Patriots
[Applause]
[Music]
and from deep in my heart thank you for
your prayers and thank you for your love
and thank you for that incredible
overwhelming support that we've had Mr
lieutenant governor thank you very much
been my friend for a long time Dad thank
you
I'm gonna go for a full screen version
of this feed I just want the best feed
for everybody okay let me see if I can
find the right feed there we go for
fighting with us too no longer with us
devastating but for seven years you and
I have been taking on the corrupt rotten
and Sinister forces trying to destroy
America and they've been trying to
destroy it they're not going to do it
but they do get closer and closer with
rigged elections they get closer and
closer
we've been the ones in this fight
standing up to the globalists and
standing up to the marxists and
Communists that's what they are we don't
even talk about the Socialists anymore
that train left that station a long time
ago Trump doesn't know the definition of
either standing up to the war mongers
the stupid War mongers and the neocons
and the Rhinos the big money special
interests the open border Fanatics crazy
people
standing up to the fake news media look
at all of them there
the only media there is right wing
[Applause]
that's a big group big group
but they don't want to tell the truth
that's why most of them are going down
the tubes you look at what's happening
with media they're going down the tubes
because they don't want to tell the
truth they don't want to talk about
what's happening with the laptop from
hell they don't want to talk about those
things and that's what's happening to
them is it but the vultures and the
sellouts who got rich bleeding America
dry
our opponents have done everything they
can to crush our spirit and to break our
will but they failed they've only made
us stronger
[Music]
and 2024 is the final battle that's
going to be the big one
you put me back in the White House their
rain will be over and America will be a
free Nation once again yes the America
is not free right now
our enemies are desperate to stop us
because they know that we are the only
ones who can stop them they know that
you know there's never been a movement
like this in the history of our country
probably in the history of almost every
country I think that's true Maga make
America great again America First Call
whatever you want
but I will tell you there's never been
in history look at this crowd as far as
the eye can see we flew over it was a
beautiful sight right as far as the eye
concern
[Applause]
and I did tell you a great lieutenant
governor I said you know Dan let's not
do one of those 50 50 areas or an area
we're a little behind let's go right
into the heart of it come on let's go
let's go where we were close to a
hundred percent right that's what we did
but as far as the eye can see the abuses
of power that we're currently witnessing
at all levels of government
will go down as among the most shameful
corrupt and depraved chapters in all of
American History it's happening right
before your eyes
but we're going to end up winning the
Biden regime's weaponization of law
enforcement against their political
opponent is something straight out of
the
stalinist Russian
Horror Show
and you know we go staliness Russia
that's what it was this was where it
seems to have begun from the standpoint
of us watching it in semi-modern Day
history you go Trump knows a lot about
history look at a third world
Banana Republic that's what we've become
between our borders our elections and
the weaponization of law enforcement
Banana Republic that's what we have
become let there be no doubt the
injustices being done not only to me but
to dozens across our country will not
stand and we're not going to stand for
it when this election is over I will be
the president of the United States
we will see my friend
thank you
you will be Vindicated and proud and the
Thugs and criminals who are corrupting
our justice system will be defeated
discredited and totally disgraced that's
what's happening
that's what's happening
from the beginning it's been one Witch
Hunt and phony investigation after
another
[Music]
and right on cue the cult members hold
up the Witch Hunt sign never talks about
greatness anymore you look at what China
does they go all over the world they
spend money they take over governments
they do a lot of things and we're always
looking we got crazy people like shift
Shifty shift
and Hillary and Adam Schiff was recently
on the show you can check out his uh
reaction to Trump calling him a
watermelon Hood on my channel buddy
but at a really under investigation I
also want to thank
the Republican Congress because you know
people can be critical but they are
working so hard Jim Jordan
James Gomer he's become a great star
these are great people and they're
putting themselves at risk because they
take a lot of abuse but they're doing
something that we haven't seen in
Washington in 25 years so I want to just
thank those two and many people that are
working with them
in my case every piece of my personal
life Financial life business life and
public life has been turned upside down
and dissected like no one in the history
of our country Marjorie I think we can
say right I think we can find anybody
they even got the Supreme Court of the
United States to give them my tax
returns something that was never
supposed to happen legal Scholars say
that's a shock it actually was Trump
said he was going to release them me
they got every single thing they wanted
about me the Supreme said oh give it to
the prosecutors that's okay
he only appointed three of them not a
lot of you know we don't want loyalty we
once or what's right but sort of strange
isn't it give them everything they want
they actually came down with run ruling
that no no you can't do that to
presidents but the Trump you can
to Trump you can
and we've been a special Administration
and we have special people there's
nobody like the people we have they're
the smartest they're the best these are
the most look at all the money they're
sitting over here they're all over
because and you know what they've made
that money the old-fashioned way you're
right front row Joe the cronyism and
pillaging America's natural resources
North Carolina
who are unbelievable beautiful
incredible women
incredible people they travel all over
what is this like number 93 I think
right number 93 oh they go no actually
more
but we appreciate it 101 Front Row Joe
101 all the Joe's
but the Supreme Court is afraid just
like Republicans are afraid to do
something about what has happened and
they have to fight the Supreme Court
didn't have the courage to right the
wrong of the 2020 election they knew
what was going on tax returns were
always considered sacred lawyers in
their own way if you can believe this
were considered sacred today lawyers go
before grand juries all over this place
if they happen to be lawyers
representing Republicans and they treat
lawyers like they're criminals it used
to be if you have this is a very myopic
view of what's going on in this
country's legal system from the
standpoint of what we're talking about
above reproach now they get thrown in
with everybody else and it's a very
unusual situation that's taking place
and again legal Scholars can't believe
what they're witnessing and yet after
going over 11 million pages of documents
I built a great company
they've got nothing they've got nothing
think of it 11 million pages
and my tax returns on top of it and
they're a big return
it probably makes me the most innocent
man in the history of our country
there it is
very successful no one's been this
innocent ever no we've never on page
three they got me
get 11 million Pages we gave over to
various groups including Congress
the new weapon being used by out of
control unhinged Democrats to cheat on
election
is criminally investigating a candidate
bad publicity and all you get bad
publicity it's the craziest thing I got
bad publicity in my poll numbers have
gone through the roof would you explain
this to me
explain that to me Dan
Mr congressman
you got to explain it to me because
nobody else has ever heard of it but you
know what it gets so much publicity that
the case actually gets adjudicated in
the press and people see it's
and they go and they say
it's unfair
but it takes place by the department of
Injustice and their local henchmen at
the AG and DA's offices throughout the
country you know they use the local
offices like in New York City this is
quite a word salad I must say in Chicago
in Los Angeles
they make lives miserable destroy their
families and friends even though they
know these people are innocent in many
cases they're Patriots
they're not guilty of anything and yet
they have to go through hell and if
you're running for office imagine
bringing your kids to one of these
events after him but we have some great
congressmen that probably they wouldn't
go after because they're too clean
they're the cleanest people I've ever
met they come from Texas they have to be
clean
but let's say they're not that well
known they're doing a good job and an
investigation has started into one of
these many great people
gonna lose that race they're going to
lose their race and they do it all the
time they're using investigations now
instead of because it's harder for them
to stuff the ballot boxes of which they
stuff plenty you know uh Marjorie is
here truth to vote and they found at
least five million instances on tape and
the courts didn't want to even look at
it the district attorney of New York
under the auspices and direction of the
Department of Injustice in Washington
D.C
was investigating me for something that
is not a crime not a misdemeanor not an
affair
I never liked horse face I never liked
[Applause]
what a clown
that wouldn't be the one
there is no one we have a great first
lady
first lady
who people really do love and she's done
an incredible job
not she quite literally accomplished
nothing and it went on and on and on and
continues to
he sacked his office with DC operatives
a man named Matthew Colangelo one of the
top people in the Department of Justice
was moved into the Manhattan DA's office
to make sure that Trump got taken care
of they couldn't get it done in
Washington so they said let's use local
offices
so they have colangela the top just
about the top one of the top people
under the Attorney General Garland
and they sent him into really a riveting
speaker and the crowd is reacting with
extraordinary excitement and do
everything he could to
get rid of trump because you know our
poll numbers are through the roof I
guess you've seen that they don't like
it
they don't like it we won in 2016 we won
by much more in 2020 but it was rigged
you know in 2020 I got the most votes of
any sitting president in history
I love how he never mentions but 8
million less than Joe Biden the history
of the in Biden won and yet they said we
lost
that what we have to do is swap them
this time the one thing that that really
does prevail and I heard all of your
different speakers talking about what to
do we used to like to hold out on
Tuesday till Tuesday and everybody goes
to their votes and then in some cases
you go in a vote and the machines are
all broken that's what they do to you
that's what they did too didn't have
some very special people it didn't
happen
we had a state in a certain State
everybody was so proud Republicans like
to vote on Tuesday they went in and the
machines a lot of the machines were
broken so they had to stand online for
10 hours and more and actually many
a few tabulators in Arizona were briefly
down everybody was redirected and
Arizona was a state that just didn't
vote for Kerry Lake lying they're good
at keeping borders open
they're good at no voter ID
why don't they want voter ID think of it
you know 88 of the Democrats want voter
ID but not the leadership there's only
one reason you don't want voter ID
because you want to cheat on elections
remember this is very deceptive many
states already have voter ID and
furthermore what we don't want is voter
ID being used as a way to prevent people
from voting which it absolutely would be
they've got to get tougher they've got
to get like Marjorie telegrin you happen
to be here
would you like to run for the Senate and
I will fight like hell for you I thought
where's Matt Gates I heard his speech oh
Matt look at that
boy
he laid it out there didn't he
I said you know I was watching I said
you know maybe he's got a little too far
and then I realized no he hasn't that's
really he's given some very good facts
and people like it that's why he wins
his district by a tremendous amount well
they weaponized him too they weaponized
him they made up phony charges and he
went through two years of hell
and he turned out to be a brave guy it
is a good test you have to say that Matt
it's a hell of a test we learn about
people it's almost like going to school
taking a test he got an A plus on that
test
right
I mean
they took the word of a proven liar
a convicted felon and a disbarred lawyer
all the same person believe it or not
you wouldn't think that could go to one
person it would be three four five
over some of the most respected and
prestigious people in the country and in
New York City some of the most respected
lawyers testifying against
they looked at all of these pages of
documents they went back to Old cases
that were summarily rejected by many
prosecutors highly respected prosecutors
Democrat prosecutors all
before including
and I will tell you the existing
prosecutor who said this case doesn't
make sense it doesn't make sense all of
a sudden pressure got put on them by
Washington D.C and the case that didn't
make sense he said let's go get Trump
they even had numerous prosecutors who
resigned because I was being treated
unfairly that made me feel so good when
I heard that that's a lie they resigned
because they thought their work was
going to waste because they weren't
actually going to indict him they
resigned a lot of them resigned the
office because they said you can't treat
a man like this he didn't do anything
wrong
but the two lead prosecutors absolute
human scum
won a Hillary Clinton lawyer from a
Hillary Clinton Law Firm do you believe
that
how about a guy who represents Hillary
Clinton
he's in a law firm that represents
Democrat it's headed up by Chuck
Schumer's brother this Law Firm Robert
Schumer think of this now think of this
and he calls up the
prosecutor
the think of this he calls up the
district attorney of Manhattan he said
I'd like to come and work for free I'm
going to leave I represent Hillary
Clinton we represent the DNC the
Democrat Party I don't even know if you
know this and he said I want to work for
free he's a bad guy known as a bad guy I
want to work for free to get Trump
and they bring him into the office he
becomes the head prosecutor then you had
another one similar and then he goes out
and he quits because
the head of the office who I respected
but then he went bad because he just an
electric speaker as you can tell
riveting the office said no we can't get
him on anything he didn't do anything
wrong change his mind a little bit on a
couple of little things but that's okay
but he was under a great deal of
pressure now I understand that he's made
up his mind and he agrees with his
original feeling that we did nothing
wrong but how about this A guy leaves
Private Practice representing Hillary
Clinton goes for no salary no anything
he goes into the District Attorney's
office to prosecute Donald Trump he
doesn't get what he wants wow so he
leaves the office in a huff and he
writes
during
the case ongoing
and I will say this he has been
absolutely killed
by the media even the fake news media
back there a lot of them I see
and they say that in itself is enough
reason that that should have stopped a
long time ago so he goes in and he
writes the book and he makes money off a
book telling what went on with the grand
jury what do you think of that Mr
lieutenant governor do you think that's
fair sounds like a fair system it's a
rig system like we had a rigged election
we have a rigged system
and you almost have to say what does our
country come to review after review even
by the biggest greatest legal Scholars
some of whom don't like Trump
like Alan dershowitz said I don't want
to vote for Trump I never voted for
Trump I don't believe him actually I
think he does but he does that to give
himself a little credibility with his
friends and Democrats maybe true he
votes for me personally but
he even said he said in sick of years of
practicing law
I can't there's no case here but I've
never that's Alan dershowitz a Democrat
Greg Jarrett who's a great scholar great
scholar great guy he came out with as a
mere curiosity you know these people
other than the ones on the the
grandstands behind Trump they're in
direct sunlight for hours and hours and
hours waiting for Trump you think
they're all wearing sunscreen honestly
to these radical left maniacs
it is worse actually in my opinion
hard to believe anything could be worse
than this but I think it's worse than
ballad stuffing or media manipulation by
the FBI working together with Twitter
Facebook and the rest remember when that
came out four weeks ago
that the FBI was working to make sure
that nothing bad is said about Biden but
as much bad as possible is said about
Trump and you know that had more of an
impact even than truth to vote with the
ballot suffering where they caught
ballots being stuffed on tape all live
aren't they didn't happen so we have to
stop them from cheating in elections
because if we don't win this next
election 2024 I truly believe our
country is doomed I think it's doomed
prosecutorial misconduct is their new
tool and they are willing to use it at
levels never seen before
in our country we've had it but we've
never had it like this we must stop them
and we must not allow them
to go through another election where
they have yet another
tool in their toolkit right remember
everything I've endured all of the hits
all of the attacks all of the assaults
and pain of my loved ones my loved ones
have
suffered
far more than I have I've you know I've
almost with me it's almost become like
I go through Russia Russia Russia phony
deal impeachment hoax number one phony
deal and Peach spin hoax number two
phony deal the Mueller Witch Hunt phony
deal by the way it's determination after
two and a half years no collusion there
was no collusion with Russia I could
have told them that very easily but they
knew that because they had the laptop
and the laptop the collusion was with
Biden and Hillary Clinton who worked
with them on the dossier you guys
understanding that by Russia
but they don't do anything about it
so
I hear that and you get a little bit
hardened to it you get a little bit
immune but they do tremendously big
damage to great people your family
members and your friends and your
Associates and people that work for you
and everybody
but I never ran for office
if I never
took on the Deep Side so I'd never ran
from oh here we go I mean I ran one time
and I won I won to be for the presidency
so that's good
I had a center to come in to see me once
a few years ago he said
sir
you've only done this for one year sorry
I've been running for office sure 28
years sorry sorry I ran for president a
couple of times
I'm greatly experienced I think you
should listen to me I said well I've
only run one time I've only been doing
it for one year and I became president
of the United States so I want to listen
to you I don't want to listen to I don't
want to listen to them
[Applause]
but if I never did run for office if I
never took on the Deep state
if I never stood up to China like no
other president has ever stood up before
you didn't even know China was a problem
until I came along China was ripping us
off making
600 billion dollars a year 600 million
and I did a little tarot he does seem
confused look in hundreds of billions of
dollars
I got the farmers of our country 28
billion dollars because of the abuse
that they had to take
the farmers love Trump
they keep saying oh I think the sanctist
can do okay with Farmers I don't think
so based based on polls he's not doing
okay with anything
well it's never good to try and Destroy
Social Security it's never good to raise
the minimum age to a very high level
which was not good and he's so confused
against Medicare and try and obliterate
it these are a few of the good facts
it's also not good when you look
statistically at how he did on covet not
well at all he's in a very bad position
or you look at how he does on crime not
good not good we have great Republican
Governors actually we did really much
better who shut down their states for a
very short time or in some cases didn't
shut them down at all I look at South
Carolina
South Dakota Tennessee I mean we had
some states that did a phenomenal job
with no shutdowns you know I gave them
the right not to shut down not everybody
you didn't have to shut down but in the
case of Florida they unfortunately did
shut it down they shut down the beaches
they shut down everything so now that
people are finding out
about what happened they're saying man
he's dropping like a rock and I wonder
why but you know you never like it when
somebody comes you see I'm a loyalist
they say Sir don't talk about that sir
because people don't want to hear that
but I do because I'm a loyal person
these people over here have been very
loyal to me Marjorie Matt
Lieutenant Governor Dan many of them
sitting right here a lot of our foreign
viewers are asking whether anyone could
really believe the things he's saying
yes the people in the crowd believe the
things he's saying I know it's hard to
believe but they do
he said almost nothing in the polls and
he's fighting somebody that's at 42 and
he's got almost 30 million dollars in
the bank he said almost nothing he's got
no cash
and I said I can't give you an
endorsement there's no way you can win
you're dead
but he fought a little bit like 150 he
was certainly know Jim Jordan that I can
tell you he forwarded a little bit just
a little bit on impeachment hoax number
one impeachment hooks number two meaning
on television because I didn't know him
very well but I saw him so he came and
he really wanted I said you can't win
can you how do you can win sir have you
endorsed me I'll win please please sir
endorse me
and I said all right let's give it a
shot because honestly the secretary of
agriculture Adam Putnam good man but I
never met him I've never known him so I
don't feel guilty about it you know if
you don't know great guy I wish I knew
him actually you want to know the truth
I wouldn't have done this so what
happened is
I said let's give it a shot Ron
and I endorsed him and he became like a
rocket ship
within one day the race was over he got
the nomination
then he had a run against a man that was
the hottest in all of politics he was
the hottest person remember it was him
and Stacey Abrams super hot in the
Democrat Party so we laugh at him now
but at the time he was one of the
hottest people in politics Matt right he
comes from a state that Matt's very
familiar with
now he turned out to be a crackhead
there you go but I did rallies for Ron
that were massive rallies and they were
very successful
so we got him the nomination
we then got him the election he said I
don't think I can make it because the
other guy was really popular believe it
or not he was going to be the next
president of the United States
but that didn't work out too well they
caught him in a crack Den
of course anything goes in politics
today he can maybe make it that's true
who knows
but think how bad Florida would be
remember one thing Florida has been
tremendously successful for many years
long before this guy became governor
Florida was tremendously successful
under Rick Scott
look whether you like him or not Charlie
Christ it was very successful he was a
republican at the time
but Florida's been successful for
decades in fact probably as or more
successful than it is now but when a man
you know you get him elected and there's
no quid pro quo get rid of that word
remember those words quid pro quo with
the perfect call I made with the
Ukrainian president really great speech
really has an arc you know moves forward
momentum because of you he wins the
election because of you
later the fake news is up there saying
will you run against the president will
you run
and he says I have no comment I say
that's not supposed to happen I have no
comment no so I'm not I'm not a big fan
but who I love I love that's right he's
a disciple of Paul Ryan he is actually a
disciple that's why he wanted to cut
Social Security and Medicare but I think
we're doing really well I mean we're up
and
all right guys as I mentioned
heart out at 7 30 tonight I've got to
get to a friend's birthday if you want
to watch the remaining four hours of
this by all means there are options
available to you which I'm sure you will
find however another possibility would
be don't watch the rest of this I'll
have a summary on Monday you'll be able
to take it all in in nine minutes would
be my prediction we're also on the
ground in Waco Texas doing interviews
today and we will have some of those
clips for you on Monday all right
everybody thanks for joining me see you
very soon